[Music]
sooners how much your mother season nine
wraps up I'm going to do a show called
Hedwig and the Angry Inch yes yes very
familiar very familiar with that with
that story and I'm curious this is a
it's a it's a transgender role yep young
so probably show done brilliantly by
John Cameron Mitchell actor director now
and they're bringing it to Broadway so
I'm playing that role of head of Hedvig
but it's yes you're playing of a
transgendered German rock pops rock
singer right and so I'm gonna have to be
like all dragged out for the whole show
have you started field with the whole
thing and I'm freaking out why do you
suppose how do you prepare for that well
let me tell you you've come to the right
place what is curious like there you
you're gonna have to like get advice on
because it's not just like I'll put on
the you know the heels it's gonna be a
whole thing and a very transformative I
mean the drag thing is not supposed to
be like shocking it's it's well beyond
that and it's the rock monologue
essentially so there's tons and tons of
songs but someone said to me you should
shave your eyebrows go on and they said
no because in drag you have to you take
a glue stick and if you don't shave your
eyebrows you have to stick you have to
glue stick the whole eyebrow and then
blow it dry and then do it again glue
stick blow it dry like six times for
each eyebrow and then you paint the
other eyebrows the feminine eyebrows
above it above it okay so they're like
you can do that which takes forever or
you could just shape it right but here's
the thing about eyebrows I always
thought that maybe it's a rumor that if
you like shaved the eyebrow it doesn't
never grow but doesn't grow back I know
I'm terrified of that I would love that
cuz then I could draw a different
expression
but do this and then wipe it clean and
her I'm mad at you I could walk around
with a marker right just because you
don't want to look like Whoopi Goldberg
I'm more worried about the eyebrows than
having to tuck my wiener down with you
know duct tape again you've come to the
right place
I'm sorry Carlos danger yeah it's not
really how they that can't be how they
really do it they also you gotta tuck
your Weiner down between your legs nice
nice it can't be duct tape
there's got to be a device that you can
purchase an infomercial thing you can
buy there must be tell me out oh it's
duct tape and then at the other night no
I'm telling you I'm telling you there's
a thing like you just thought about how
you get the duct tape off yeah trust me
it's not pleasant and so there's got to
be a device that hooks on and then
there's a crank and it pulls it back and
back
sounds like you've got your next
celebrity endorsement yeah Brian's
Weiner keeper I'm gonna start working on
this thing right now you having trouble
tucking your penis cut no Brian here
demonstrate is my friend Andy rector
[Applause]